bonjour à tous et à toutes alors j'ai
une voix bizarre
excusez moi j'ai perdu ma voie
habituelle dans un meeting à montrouge
jeudi lors le meeting était très réussie
je remercie notre nouveau délégué de
circonscription clément forestier et
clément si tu veux bien me rendre ma
voix et m'a apporté ce sera sympa ça
aidera j'écoute depuis ce matin j'ai
écouté ceux qui ont pris la parole à
cette tribune
j'ai écouté ce qui tout à l'heure votez
avec moi à l'urne là bas et je me suis
fait plusieurs remarques
d'abord tous ensemble on partage quelque
chose qui n'appartient qu'à nous le
vieux compagnonnage il est pas mort
c'est notre marque et elle nous
distinguera je crois pour toujours
quelle que soit notre nom quelle que
soit notre logo quel que soit notre
direction elle nous distinguera pour
toujours de tous les autres partis on
est un parti de militants alors ça veut
pas dire qu'on n'est pas les uns ou les
autres maires conseiller départemental
conseiller régional député ancien
ministre ou même nicolas ancien
président de la république mais d'abord
c'est pas une majorité
et puis on est tous des militants et je
vous dis tout ça pour vous dire que je
suis heureuse d'être là avec vous en
dépit de ma voix et je me sens à la
maison je me réjouis aussi aujourd'hui
de voir que nous sommes tous occupés à
un exercice démocratique
en élisant formellement un président ou
une présidente on saura tout à l'heure
cher michel chaire l'udc pour notre
conseil national si la suite logique des
élections locales qui ont eu lieu voilà
quinze jours et dans lesquelles nous
avons été élus délégués de cirque au
représentant notre fédération à ce
parlement de notre parti
j'ai beaucoup voulu cette réforme de nos
statuts pour plus de démocratie et plus
de décentralisation
j'ai défendu avec toi nicolas nous
l'avons fait voter à notre congrès
fondateur des républicains
en mai dernier et ce qui compte
maintenant et c'est votre responsabilité
c'est la mise en oeuvre non seulement la
lettre des statuts ça c'est fait vous
êtes ici à la suite de cette élection
aussi nous tous mais c'est la mise en
oeuvre de l'esprit de nos stature et
l'esprit des statuts c'est plus
d'autonomie pour les militants
c'est la prise de responsabilité à tous
les étages nous devons prendre des
risques prendre des risques pour aller
au-devant des français qui en peuvent
plus du sentiment que les politiques se
protège alors qu'eux mêmes sont exposés
à tous les vents de la mondialisation
prendre des risques en nous mais lente
tous les débats et prendre des risques
en défrichant des idées nouvelles et
c'est ma troisième réflexion on a le
devoir d'être novateur notre famille
politique soit les rangs des librairies
ces temps ci et il paraît que cela
pourrait encore s'enrichir et bah c'est
une belle et bonne chose il ya en france
une déception il ya une méfiance
il ya parfois un dégoût de la politique
la prochaine campagne ça doit être
l'occasion de partager une espérance
notre objectif en 2017
c'est pas d'être élus de la même manière
que françois hollande a pu l'être en
2012 nous on doit être élu parce que les
français cette fois là auront envie de
nous je m'efforce d'apporter ma pierre à
ce débat et si les idées par exemple de
choc fiscal iconoclaste qui a huit mois
cher eric que j'ai pu lancer alors sont
aujourd'hui de retour autrement tant
mieux en tout cas sur toutes ces
questions qui traversent nos sociétés
qu'ivry nos certitudes on va pas pouvoir
arriver en disant on fera linverse des
socialistes
et on va pas pouvoir arriver non plus en
10 ans on fera enfin ce qu'on a déjà
promis et ce qu'on n'a pas réalisé
pour dire les choses autrement en 2017
on pourra pas juste reprendre le fil de
là où on l'a laissé d'abord parce
qu'entre temps il ya eu 50 françois
hollande c'est à dire cinq ans de tout
de rien surtout de rien cinq ans à
prendre du retard sur le fond d'économie
cinq ans a joué d'habileté politique il
en a et symboles encore cette semaine
avec une révision constitutionnelle qui
ne sert à rien alors que dans le même
temps le chômage explose les entreprises
sont à la peine et toute une génération
de jeunes français se demandent si son
avenir n'est pas ailleurs 50 perdu donc
mais aussi cinq ans pendant lesquels le
monde a changé et plus encore
nous avons changé de monde regardez ce
qui se passe dans tous les domaines la
société est profondément transformé par
le numérique économie et bousculé comme
jamais la sécurité et la lutte contre le
terrorisme
en somme un tel état qui nous amène même
à parler de guerre mais en 2017
on pourra pas juste reprendre le fil de
là où on l'a laissé il va falloir
innover il va falloir nous renouveler
profondément pour pouvoir transformer la
france chance quelques idées quelques
exemples dans des secteurs totalement
différent d'un monde du travail
bien sûr il faut sortir des 35 heures
mais faut pas juste revenir aux 39
heures faut pas rester dans ce débat des
35 heures payées 39 et 39 payées 35 et
37 payer 38 amy et on ne sait plus quoi
ça on aurait dû le faire en 2002 non il
faut supprimer la durée légale unique
nationale du travail elle a plus de sens
et la durée doit être négocié dans les
branches ou dans les entreprises sur le
contrat de travail
bien sûr qu'il faut alléger le contrat
travail code du travail mais enfin il
faut surtout prendre en compte le fait
majeur du monde du travail qui est
l'émergence du travail indépendant ça
avait commencé à être fait finalement
avec l'auto entrepreneur le numérique
qui bouscule tous les modèles ça sert à
rien de le déplorer il faut y faire face
troisième exemple on parle de
dégressivité des allocations chômage
dans le temps faim le gouvernement nous
en parle et il le fera pas comme
d'habitude
pourquoi pas c'est sans doute une bonne
idée mais ce serait au moins aussi
important de travailler à une
dégressivité réel immédiate quand on
refuse une offre d'emploi raisonnable et
d'une certaine manière ce serait moins
automatique mais ce serait plus juste
et puis enfin ça suffit de s'occuper
toujours de faire des réformes pour le
privé et seulement pour le privé comme
si on osait pas toucher au secteur
public
la première responsabilité me
semble-t-il la politique c'est bien de
réformer l'administration parfois
l'administration dont il a la charge
avant d'aller dire aux entrepreneurs
comment ils doivent gérer leur barque et
je parle pas juste du non renouvellement
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux je souhaite
qu'on sorte du statut de la fonction
publique pour toutes les fonctions pour
lesquelles il n'est pas justifié
et elles sont nombreuses et on en a tous
en tête inspirons-nous des expériences
britannique et italienne
ils ont pris de l'avancé en matière de
réformes voilà quelques exemples y en
aurait d'autres il m'amène à une
dernière réflexion à partager avec vous
je crois que les idées nouvelles
formeront le coeur de la reconquête
les idées plus que les personnes il n'y
a pas d'homme providentiel
et je vous dis pas ça pour vous dire
qu'il ya des femmes providentiels c'est
pareil ça existe pas non plus l'image de
celui qui se lève qui va à la rencontre
des français
elle est gravement altérée un homme seul
n'a carnera ni la sagesse ni l'énergie
ni le courage ni le renouveau ni la
providence ce temps là il est révolu
c'est la richesse de nos débats c'est la
réalité l'exercice démocratique ouvert
transparent pluraliste qui fera la force
de notre candidat et là je sais que nous
nous retrouverons tous pour la victoire
je remercie